The Joe Rogan Experience in fact they
say that exercise is one and a half
times more effective than ssris for
curing depression oh in a heartbeat man
I'll tell if I take my because I take
ssris and I do exercise if I take my
SSRI I don't feel really anything I just
feel like oh I took my SSRI but if I go
for a run like even today I had to go
run a couple miles I was like I know I'm
going to be on here I want to have
I want to like just be in like my I want
to have my good energy going I'm going
to go for a run you know and so yeah I
think it I know that it makes me feel
better if I do something athletic you
know what SSR are you taking I think I'm
on Lexapro right now I take the generic
one whatever the cheaper one is
you know I think it's
um I don't know what it is but it is
they say it's fine
you know so I don't know if I believe
them but I mean I'm [__] taking it
now I would like to tell I would like to
maybe take 30 days off and try Ayahuasca
again I feel like I'm getting back
around where
I would like to do it again you know
yeah yeah
dude I would man because I want to
[__] feel I want to be right up there
on Nature's [__] I want to be in
there eavesdropping on Nature's nuts boy
I think God I'll be right up there yeah
would you say boy and eavesdropping on
nature right up next to it oh dude
yelling it oh Ayahuasca dude you'll
[__] Mother Nature you'll be she'll
break out that wiener and you'll be like
damn I didn't know Mother Nature had a
wiener you know it's nothing they just
got everything it's powerful dude that
Ayahuasca stuff is real powerful so I
would like to do that again dude what is
what is the reason why you take the
ssris
I think because when I'm off of them
something feels wrong I feel
it's a battle a battle it's a battle to
even if I do running and I do Fitness
right it's a battle to keep myself even
so instead of dealing with that at a
more intense level I choose to take them
because it just makes it a little bit
easier I don't think it's taking the
easy way out though because
if I don't take them and I still do all
those things it's hard for me to get to
a good Baseline what do you mean by
wrong like when you say you feel wrong
what does it feel like
I feel like at any moment kind of my
feelings can just drop off into like a
really surprised low hmm out of nowhere
for no reason yes sometimes with a
little bit of motivation to it right or
some trigger but it'll make the level
that it drops off to it's too much of a
drop
for me to not get some help if we're a
little bit and it felt manageable that's
okay but when it's pretty steep it's
like oh man this feels sometimes scary
yeah I know what you're saying
um but it's gotten
doing that Ayahuasca stuff made it a lot
better than it had ever been Neil um
Brennan said it basically cured him yeah
he's the one who took me to it yeah he
said um it made him much happier it
cured him of like a lot of his what he
felt like were personality disorders
that he had you know like Neil's a
Neil's a great guy be very very smart
very smart and sometimes you know I
wonder about real smart guys they're
just always thinking about things and
maybe too much about certain things and
you know you just get overwhelmed by
thoughts and anxiety and emotions and
and anxiety is a lot of what anxiety a
lot of is fretting about possibilities
for a lot of people you know it's the
inability to live in the moment and you
forgot about anxiety and a lot of it has
to do with childhood trauma a lot of it
has to do with genetics a lot of anxiety
is a weird thing like they think that
anxiety whether it's a learned behavior
or not
um you can actually get it from your
parents I don't know why see what's it I
could see that can you get anxiety is
anxiety genetic Google that my mom made
us anxious yeah yeah dude sometimes Mama
we go get ice cream dude and she would
like she's like if she'd get angry if we
she'd get so angry if we dripped any of
it here it goes there's clear research
showing that anxiety is influenced by
genetics in fact experts notice a family
connection for anxiety even before they
understood how DNA or genes worked if
you have a close relative with anxiety
your chance of developing is about two
to six times higher than if you don't
well I don't know if that's genetic or
if it's just like it's Behavior yeah if
your mom is always or your dad is always
like Bob they're [__] anxious and
they're right if they come over and
they're always [__] tickling you then
you're gonna [__] feel tickled all
this if you're always getting [__]
with yeah yeah something you know even
just tickling in with their words yeah
genetics of generalized anxiety disorder
and related traits well for sure mental
illness is uh genetic there's a lot of
people that are mentally ill and their
children are mentally ill or their
families mentally ill or you know it's
like it's
man I I used to have a much more
um
ignorant view on mental health because I
have my own mental health issues which
I'm sure we all do but mine was like
just don't be a [__] get your work done
you feel great and I don't have to take
anything and even though I don't have to
take anything I'm still doing something
to mitigate it I'm doing something every
day to work on it and when I don't I do
feel it right like a lot of people do so
I always wonder maybe those people just
aren't doing the work maybe if they just
got up in the morning went running
before work or did something before
maybe they could get through this and
not need a [__] pill yeah I don't
think that anymore interesting yeah I
think it's
I think yeah there's times where I
thought that I'm just not Tough Enough
I'm just not doing enough I'm not I'm
not enough to battle this right right
and um and then I get to a point where
so many times I tried to stop taking it
it's like it's too much of a discrepancy
that makes things unmanageable to a
point where it feels like it's unfair to
be that unmanageable to myself so
um I get back on it you know and
and I don't think it really bothers me
or anything like that but yeah it's kind
of the same with alcoholism like I
thought alcoholism used to just be like
somebody
couldn't stop drinking or whatever right
but there's so much more I mean
alcoholism is the only disease it will
tell you you don't have the disease
right
that's correct like imagine if you put
on like
a shirt right but every every couple
days a shirt was like guess what you
don't have a shirt on
I don't think that's a good analogy
I don't know if it is but it seems like
it but that's what alcohol is alcoholism
would tell you you don't have a problem
right you don't have a problem have
another drink yeah relax have another
have haven't have some more coke um yeah
have another family